would you like to hear a joke i would
love a joke it's something the people i
feel need a joke right now because you
know times are really weird this is not
my joke
you didn't write this no sir it's just
what they call a street joke good but my
dad would always tell this joke it was
about a little boy called dirty johnny
you know and he'd be in class you ever
heard dirty dirty johnny jokes yes
seriously
and this
this joke
he's not dirty
but anyways
[Music]
the teacher
has a thing and the teacher says today
in class um class
we are going to uh have a little
experiment you're going to tell a story
from your real life and then afterwards
you are going to tell the moral of that
story
you know
so uh
sheila puts up her hand and the teacher
says sheila what's your story so sheila
says well
my dad works at the hatchery
and
he took uh some eggs
and um
and he put them all in a basket
all the eggs he put in one basket
and then he put him in the horse and
buggy and off we went to town and the
earth was uneven
and the eggs broke
and uh and the teacher goes well that's
not right story but i i can't understand
what the what the moral would be to that
story
so sheila says well the moral is
don't put
all of your eggs into one basket
so the teacher says well by god this is
exactly what i'm looking for and what i
was hoping for with this experiment yeah
and anybody else have one
so uh
marjorie puts up her hand
okay margie what's your story well my
father works for the hatchery
most of us
most people in that town work in the
house not the hatchery thank god for the
hatchery she said
where would we be
so she says my father
he sells chickens
and he knows that eggs become chickens
see what i mean
so uh he had to count his chickens uh so
he'd go in and sell them in town so he
had nine chickens and five eggs so
instead of saying he had nine chickens
he added the five eggs you see he
counted them as chickens so he said i
have 14
chickens
so
he
took them sheila says
put them in the horse and buggy and now
if they went to town but the
the land was uneven
chickens
just survived easily
they frolicked
the eggs broke
well the teacher says again that's a
story you know
but
what what on earth could the
could the moral of that story be
well how sheila says if that's her name
i forgot
she says
don't count your chickens before they
hatch
out of the eggs
right teacher says you could probably
shorten it a little
so
but that's great and that's exactly what
we're looking for
and then she looks at the back of the
class and by god there's
[ __ ] up raised hands uh
because you say [ __ ] dirty journey
[ __ ] daddy daddy she's gonna ruin the
lesson
so the teacher and her inside of her
head her thoughts are moving around and
she's like
ah god i don't want to hear dirty johnny
said this is going so well but
at the same time i took a vow and i
became a teacher that every student
all right johnny let's hear your story
so dirty johnny gets up and he says
this is a story about my uncle terry
he didn't work for the hatchery
i don't even like people that did
he was in vietnam
and he lives in the disability checks he
got
uncle terry was not a popular man
not even among
those he worked with
and i suppose we've all heard of people
who've deserted from their battalion
but i don't know if you've ever heard of
a battalion deserting a man that's what
they did
with uncle terry one day uncle terry
awoke
in the middle of da nang
and everybody was gone
he was alone and they'd left him three
bottles of jack daniels
and some weaponry
so
uncle terry got up says dirty john and
he down the bottle
of
jack daniels and two slugs and he threw
it down and smashed it into the
into the jungle
and
then he walked picked up the two
kalishnikovs and three or four glocks
and a couple of hand grenades and
off he walked
into the
into the unknown the jungle
his fate
came upon a village
and from the village
came
people
now were they charlie
or were they
the people
that terry was sent to protect from
charlie
uncle terry didn't know
but
he knew he had to do something so he
took us another swig from the bottle
and he let loose
took that kalishnik off
and he he
let it sway like a
like a farmer would a scythe
and uh the bullets came and uh just as
hay would fall
before a farmer
so the people fell before uncle terry
the men the women
and by god even the children
and finally uncle terry stood alone in
the mud and the blood and the guts and
the
[Music]
only at himself
he took a long swig
and his hand brushed against his
his pants and he felt wetness and
and then he felt shame because he
realized he had urinated himself in fear
and then
upon
closer inspection he realized
it was not urine
it's ejaculated
and the shame
was replaced by pride
then teacher goes holy [ __ ] [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] kind of [ __ ] story is that
like we just heard the hatchery and [ __ ]
and now this
she was well dirty johnny what on earth
could be the the
moral to such a story
so johnny thinks about it for a couple
minutes and he goes well i don't know i
guess
well i know one thing
you know [ __ ] with terry when he's had
some drinking them
and he's uncorked the jug you stay away
from uncle jerry
i don't like anybody that works at the
hatchery either you remember that
you tell your parents that
wow so that's just a lightening thing
what a joke your dad told you that
your dad was a great storyteller that
was my dad's story though he taught us
to laugh again norm thank you look at
that ejaculated right in his pants
the thrill of killing the thrill of it
well who knows well who knows who knows
what it was
who knows what would happen if you were
putting that thank you for that story i
mean we always talk about going back and
oh if you can only go back in time and
kill hitler
right yeah but what i mean what a horror
it would be to go back in time meet
hitler and get hypnotized by him
and like him and then become one of the
guys
even
worse they say he was a very powerful
speaker you didn't know you know all of
a sudden you're killing it they say he
was a powerful speaker then on youtube
he's like
[ __ ] christ
don't vote for him but for anyone else